dings crying what's up everyone welcome
back to the changeling podcast dig dig
dig dig them now in front of a green
screen it's not exciting along in front
of that boring sound board and it's been
about hours but at least now it's dope
right yeah and this is all thanks to our
twitch fan and for those of you that
watch and listen to the podcasts that
have supported us
you have now funded us the ability to
have this awesome green screen which we
would have other not otherwise not been
able to do and it's not all the way done
getting set up
we are still ways to work but we're
we're almost there guys we have so many
possibilities now Wow we should just put
a picture impossibear
that's a good idea this podcast is
brought to you by Bowlin Branch get your
luxury bedding for affordable prices go
to bowl and branch comm enter product
code Jenna Julian and you get 50 bucks
off your first order it's also brought
to you by blue apron have readily
prepared ingredients for a delicious
meal delivered right to your doorstep
healthy beautifully fresh and just to
your liking style meals I mean they're
really delicious go to blue apron comm
slash Jenna Julian and the first two
meals are on us so thank you to our
sponsors thank you sponsors yeah so I
mean just for a second let's just let's
just take this in because well some
people might be listening and they can't
see it just imagine in your mind how
awesome it is yeah like it's it's wild
the first time you know you see it it's
very interesting it's so bright in here
like it looks like we like when we tried
on the Twitter stream last night when we
first that area it looks like it's
daytime in here it's a moment you'll
have to excuse my voice and if you can
hear me sucking on some candy by the way
because I for some reason lost my voice
this week but yeah Jenna's doing a
little bit about
cold um it looks like it's daylight in
here yeah that's right he's not it's
pretty great well what the green screen
does behind us is we've we've always had
the lighting in front of us but the
greens room behind is kind of like
bounces the light back so it's light
coming from everywhere which is really
nice and it provides really happy
looking environment and we get to put
whatever the [ __ ] we want behind us we
test it out a couple dynamic backgrounds
things that were moving I shot a couple
back backgrounds you know in the
backyard of like walls and and it was a
little distracting nauseous well we'll
work in different things but we're going
to start slow with backgrounds and
hopefully you like this one this one
seemed pretty appropriate you know
wasn't too loud and stuff but um yeah so
you know we'll get creative you guys
have good ideas we'll always listen to
you guys yeah the top requested one was
just a live stream of the dogs like
sleeping how weird would that be though
if they were like as big as us so behind
us like it's so huge the regular honey
have you seen like like it's like on a
news blooper highlight reel on YouTube
like one of those news bloopers and you
know how like a lot of news stations
have behind them a projection of like a
city yeah but it's a green-screen it's
really just like a live feed
well the live feed is a camera at the
top of this building and this pigeon
landed right in front of the live feed
so behind them was just giant ass pigeon
blocking the whole thing oh it's amazing
yeah we should do that yeah we should
just like you know those Fox cams are
like Eagle cams we should just set one
of those up yeah do you know that
there's a live street this totally ran
view there's a live stream of Abbey Road
no yeah on the internet somewhere I
found it but you can see people trying
to recreate the like Beatles photograph
oh my god Oh like 24/7 there's a lot of
he did yes I know there was someone was
periscoping recently just like a puddle
after it rained because people really
jumping through it but then people
realize it was on periscope and we're
going to it they can jump in a car was
pretty cool but also there were some
beta fish-- that had been playing a
video game I can't remember how do you
remember seeing that remembers like
every time they would swim in a certain
way would like press a
oh my god that's brilliant yeah I forget
what the game was you're gonna have to
remind me something stupid for a memory
really birthday I think they had just
completed something I'll look up right
now it's worth it it's worth it I
promise that is dope yeah so like right
now there's a background behind us on
the twitch stream it's just like our
heads cut out and the game is behind us
so it's really trippy looking it's
awesome but I'm honest I mean I'm
honestly pretty surprised with how well
this is come out considering I have no
formal training in the sub Jenna has no
formal training in the stuff and yet it
like it looks semi-professional yeah so
exactly two fish are playing Street
Fighter - oh my god so explain how this
works
okay I'll read you a part of the article
that was written on the verge oh this
was a couple years ago but there's more
recently but apparently it's a thing
that exists right this minute Aquarius
and Robert the Bruce okay - fish are
battling to the death in an epic game of
Street Fighter 2 turbo the two fish live
in a fish tank wired up to a camera that
tracks their movements and doles out the
appropriate commands to the video game
oh my god it's like okay this is the one
I was remembering fish plays Pokemon but
more hardcore so that's really fun but
there was a thing fish plays Pokemon I
want to look that one up yeah it's a
live stream live stream is proof that
fish should not play pokemon god that is
hilarious yeah I love like the ingenuity
of the human spirit goes towards things
like that that's what I'm talking about
well I forget what it was that an eagle
cam or like a [ __ ] I know there was an
eagle cam oh I saw that yeah yeah and
there was another Fox truck with a GoPro
or something yeah but it happened like a
couple years ago or maybe three or four
years ago it was like all the rage
everyone's like oh my god this is so
[ __ ] rad and the website was like
getting crashed by all the traffic
mm-hmm but it's still a cool idea the
novelty of watching animals live has not
worn off
yeah no absolutely for sure yeah that's
not as crazy
there was a video uh that kind of got
big this week it was of this super [ __ ]
I forget the name of it super moto
something it was these motorcycle race
in [ __ ] somewhere not America going
200 miles an hour and so I'm going to go
pro on the front is and it is nausea I
mean it's like it's one it's one of the
craziest things to be like too even so I
assume the role of someone going that
fast down those trees like it got to the
point where he's going so fast that even
he was going in and out of shadows and
the shadows would have made me like lose
my mind because it's like flashing its
it was the craziest thing I'm sure a lot
of of are seen it but man that is trippy
like GoPros are trippy no no that's not
the stream for me thank you
that's a video for me I watched you
watching something like that and it made
me nauseous just on and it's pretty fun
I feel like people's brains are
different like my brain cannot process
information that quickly thank you
well yeah I can't yeah like if you think
about baseball or softball like I can
hit a very fast pitch yeah it takes you
a long time to learn how to do that I
imagine it takes me pull very long time
in order to learn how to drive very fast
I can't because a pitch is a pitch a
different road scape of other drivers
and trees and it's just a different
landscape every single time my brain
can't do that yeah I really need to be a
very special person in order to drive a
vehicle really fast yes yes I mean I'm
not that special person but you
definitely like because in this video
you're seeing them take turns and click
not even slow down at some points
because they're the in their mind you
got to think that they've completely
blocked out the idea of falling like
they can't even be close to the
forefront of your of your thought
process because if it is you're going to
fall so they've by this point I mean
this is just me inferring but this is
you know in the race they are not
thinking about falling the other thing
the angles the thing about their speed
there you know the thrust of their
acceleration maybe drafting behind
someone else in the race or someone else
in the race hitting them like just
things that are right in front of them
they're not even considering the idea
that they could fall and kill themselves
or paralyze our whole body and like that
takes something that you are so
amazingly focused on this one thing on
this one race I'm not for me
fundamentals that you don't even think
about falling like I mean that's crazy
to me no not for me that is crazy it's
just should we put that as the
background no the motors are going to
it's like it's like a like a 15 minute
video just doesn't end for 50 minutes
no I already show up yeah I would throw
up podcasting in front of the green
screen but I thought it's not gonna say
go just thinking about it yeah well
today we didn't really plan on talking
about nauseating things on a green
screen although that's relevant we did
want to talk about something else that
has been requested quite a bit we want
to talk about YouTube networks it's been
less if you were we weren't going to
talk about conspiracy theories but
because this is our third time now
talking about conspiracy theories we
need a little extra time for research at
this point yeah so we were gonna do that
today
but I think in maybe next week or the
week after we'll have some really gonna
be a better version yes we we want to
make sure that we have all the
information that we can present in a
coherent form and not just like oh
here's the idea and then you don't get
to explain it yeah we want to make it
worthwhile so you guys so when we do
present part three do conspiracy
theories it will be dope
yeah I'll tweet that out too so people
aren't like what the [ __ ] is this
podcast yeah cuz we asked for ideas for
conspiracy yeah so this week we wanted
to talk about YouTube networks because
well we're in the world of YouTube a lot
of you a lot of you have Titan brothers
yes a lot of you requested it because of
that in general I feel like a good
amount of you are curious as to what
YouTube networks do and
why why they exist so let's start I mean
I say we saw a pretty pretty basic why
don't you explain what a YouTube network
is good why not cuz it's alright are we
already getting there ah yeah
so YouTube network is basically a
business or a corporation of people that
take youtubers together much like a
television network like you would have a
show or something on your on CBS or NBC
and they all fall under your umbrella
but instead of shows their youtubers
exactly channels yeah and instead of
like oh you know we have run thick rest
I don't know what I'm saying you're a
youtuber and you're you so what you
again I'm just checking the plug bang
but you're you're theoretically under an
umbrella that is like similar to a
station on a television show mm-hmm and
many of them provide management they
provide brand deals or opportunities for
you to make income outside of your
Google Adsense and oftentimes provide
you with the ability to have legal
backing or things like that if part of
what you're doing is an independent
youtuber you need some support they will
be there to do that for you and yeah
that's the gist of it and so there's a
lot of YouTube networks out there um
just to be clear they take a cut so when
you mate when you make a YouTube channel
and you're making money off Adsense you
are able to get 100% of that money that
you've earned whether it's you know five
hundred dollars or whether it's ten
thousand dollars you know I mean you get
all of it when you're the network that
is different so when you sign with the
network they now receive that Adsense
and give you your cut right so they get
it first like they they have they not as
far as I'm concerned they get to see the
analytics on your YouTube they take
their cut and then they give you yours
yep
you know that kind of frightens me even
if I agreed to like say I sound with the
network and I agreed to like a 70/30
split where I was getting 70% of the
Adsense which I think it's stupid and
they were getting 30 and I got my check
every month I would still be like is
this really 70% like I don't have the
ability to like look anymore they stay
usurp that role so that's one thing
that's how they make their money that's
how they stay afloat and that's what
they grow which is very controversial
because a lot of times YouTube networks
especially for youtubers like myself and
Jenna are completely unnecessary you
know we're able to accomplish anything
we need to accomplish without the use of
that sort of thing and yet I think the
problem is a lot of YouTube networks
market themselves is something that
people need or something that younger
creators need and don't know better than
to say no to so I don't know I'm really
good I think that YouTube networks the
only reason why open let me reframe this
the reason why we wanted to make this
podcast is there are a lot of people
that make youtube videos um you know on
whatever scaler level you started
yesterday or you started five years ago
or ten years ago that just want to hear
somebody else's opinion because we don't
often talk a lot about that within the
YouTube community you know especially
before raywilliamjohnson sort of outed
maker at which i think is still online
if you wanted to google that he was one
of the first youtubers that really took
a stand and was like [ __ ] you guys
you're doing me dirty because people
just did not talk about it years ago I'm
gonna take this out there you go you
stay there we just didn't talk about it
and that was still around the time when
although there are people now people
just think that you make no money by
using the internet which we all know is
not true but there are so many people
that will come up to me and say how do
you make money they just don't
understand even though you've been able
to monetize on YouTube since wet
seven people just don't get it so they
don't they don't really understand why a
network could exist or how they exist or
how they could make money it's just all
very foreign to them but the majority
people now understand that's a thing
but even five years ago a lot of people
are in the dark but we still have for
some reason don't are in this culture of
like we don't really talk about networks
which is neither here nor there
but I understand that a lot of people
want to hear us talk about it because I
do have thoughts or you have thoughts
and opinions but it is coming from a
little bit of a place of like is this
inside baseball for us to talk about
this on a podcast on a YouTube channel
is it inside baseball to talk about
networks because there's plenty people
that listen to this podcast as a source
of entertainment and aren't you know
concerned about [ __ ] do networks I
got [ __ ] but because it was requested I
am going to give you the information
that I can give you or that I'm willing
to give you um and you can do that as
well at your own discretion yeah but in
my flat out opinion I think that it's
very difficult for me to justify why
networks exists and I have a good
working relationship with many networks
I think there's a lot of youtubers that
do there's no reason to dislike these
people all the people that run them for
the most part are wonderful people yeah
they're most of them are not in it to
you know [ __ ] people over they're like
really great people and I understand a
hundred percent because I was in that
position when I lived in Boston and I
first started YouTube you know I felt
alone like totally on lonely island
there's no one in Boston that's doing
this right now I you know even my own
box at the time didn't understand what
the [ __ ] I was doing Europe and it was
very confusing for people to see that as
an option for you to spend your time
doing even as a [ __ ] hobby it's you
know laughable little [ __ ] are you doing
and when I was approached I you know on
the internet by a management company at
the time who specialized in managing
internet people yeah which was not the
mole
popular thing I think maker where some
of the other ones were like the be at
the beginning stages of that yes in
terms of not just being like an MCN also
just like offering people management
yeah I think like that's all they start
yeah a lot of them either started one
way or the other they started just
managing people or just like
collaborating numbers together to sell
higher CPM whatever whatever the [ __ ] so
I was approached by a management company
that just did management services which
then got absorbed and turned into big
frame but it was wonderful for me to
feel like okay I have someone that
understands what's going on much better
than I do and I'm remote I don't live in
a place where you know people are
working in this field I feel very alone
and I also don't know where to go from
here because at the time I was doing all
of that for myself and I know a lot of
people that start out on the internet do
this for years which I did you answer
every email that comes through your
email inbox you get these very bizarre
offers for you know bizarre things you
don't know where to go you don't know
which ones are serious which one should
I you don't know how to navigate at all
yeah you don't know how much your time
is worth in different areas like if
someone's like hey I'll give you $10 to
do this and you're like well I don't see
why not
yeah you don't know you have no gauge
it's very confusing
um and it's very overwhelming and scary
because you're just a person that
doesn't know anything just with the
[ __ ] head cut off just thrown into
the water like alright well now I got
learn house with and it was very
comforting and because I was making
almost zero dollars on YouTube for them
to be like hey our price is 10% of your
Google Adsense and we'll manage you for
free or for 10% sorry and then the rest
of that is yours and I was like okay
well since I'm making a grand total of
zero [ __ ] dollars ten percent of zero
is not a big deal and I can understand
that I understand that mentality because
there are so many people that start as a
young person that feel lost and it's you
know their parents can't help
their friends can't help them they don't
literally know no one in their town or
their city that's doing what they're
doing that even gets it or but maybe
you're in some different part of the
world where you feel extra isolated or
you know confused because this is you
know happening a lot in America as
opposed to some other countries very
confusing but networks and management
companies have now decided that this is
a really good strategy to get money from
people which is you know reach out to
anyone that has X amount of subscribers
tell them that UD should be send them an
email that says dear Jenna Julianne pod
we saw your channel and it's great like
automated [ __ ] right and to get them to
you know sign over their numbers their
10% because if you're not making a lot
of money it doesn't matter you know if
my advice to anyone that's currently in
that situation is and I'll give you
advice as I go along you know down the
rabbit hole here if you are in the
position of the first level of like I
don't know what to do should I sign with
the network that is 100 percent at your
own discretion I think that you should
get to know the people that are
contacting you talk to somebody on the
phone don't deal with you know an email
do not do business like that that is not
okay you need to talk to a human being
and don't be afraid to ask like
straight-up questions even if you're
afraid of sounding dumb just like be
like speak English example speaking but
if you don't speak English and this
other person can't find a translator or
like they just want to do business
through electronically then they don't
they're not being serious
think about your how am I going to give
you that you're a Japanese youtuber and
this person wants to approach you to
sign you because they want to do
business with you they better provide
the translator for you this is not like
a you need to bend over backwards so
that you can be with a network that is
backwards we are in a democratized
platform you have more power as a
creator than it has ever had before
we've essentially caught out middlemen
by doing everything ourselves so you
have to know that you have the power to
say yes or no to networks at your own
discretion
and I was lucky enough when I first
started working with management company
that they were legitimate people you
know I did my best to do my due
diligence and find out what they were
about but they're legitimate that
they're gonna bring me you know the
money that they said that they were
going to which you know worked out well
and they are wonderful people and I
worked with them for a while that was
really a great time and they brought me
a lot of opportunities that I would not
have had otherwise but you do need to do
that step before you take any step
because what I get nervous about is the
and it's well known at this point the UM
I don't want to name particular names I
because [ __ ] [ __ ] it but they will
send you an email a mass email that says
please sign up for our network and
people are they think that this is novel
to them like oh my god this their baby I
[ __ ] yeah good I got with a net worth
yeah yeah well cuz I mean that that
status it's a status thing to I
straining it's like a you know I've met
a mount of younger youtubers at certain
events and we're in conversation and the
last so what network are you with and
I'll tell them I'm not with a network
and it blows their mind it's like why
how like when did you get the option to
just say no or not be with it it's just
so foreign because the status is if
you're a youtuber and you take yourself
seriously you are with a network right
and this doesn't mean anything against
those plenty of successful youtubers out
there who are with networks because a
lot of it makes sense for them only I'll
get into that it wasn't that but um I
just think I think you know they prey on
a lot of situations to make money this
is the biggest downside to a network is
that in my opinion straight up flat out
if you are a new youtuber although this
is always at your discretion of what you
need personally but the only real reason
you should be signing with the network
is if you need production support like
epic Rap Battles of History like I have
this great idea I just physically cannot
make it happen and here's my writing
like I've proved myself you know III
want to do this you might need to work
your way up for a while but if you
really need production support you could
sign with a network and have them you
know give you the money and the things
to make your project come to life
it's a very hard thing to do to get to
that point to have someone give you
money to make your production happen
your other option is to do it yourself
and you know work up and save up until
you get to a point where you can do that
for yourself which is hard but there is
no reason why especially now with things
that exist uh you know although they're
all kind of so new but like a niche or
like the shays blue book that's a
commercial Blue Bottle book but there's
technologies coming into place that
essentially eliminate yeah for a network
so that you are no longer like required
to give 10% of your income to a
middleman because what's happening to
people is that they sign with a network
under the impression that they're going
to be brought brand deals or things that
might you know make them extra income
and the network just doesn't bring it to
them because the fact of the matter is
you are one youtube channel amongst
thousands or hundreds of thousands and
there is not the manpower or time to
bring you the things that they said that
they would so they are essentially
taking ten percent of your money even if
that's thirty dollars even if they don't
do anything even if they do nothing and
if it's $30 a month now and then you
spend two years of your life growing
your business and your brand and your
company and whatever you want to do with
your life you know somewhere down the
line it's going to turn into a
significant amount of money that you've
given them even as a lump sum or
sometimes for nothing
it is sometimes for absolutely nothing
and if you have a hard conversation with
yourself and you're like alright I've
given 10% of my money to this company
for X years or X time or it's turned
into this much money yeah you know what
what have you offered to me and you need
to treat it like a business relationship
like I'm giving you ten percent of my
adsense no matter if you have five
[ __ ] subscribers the deal needs to be
fair if you're giving someone ten
percent of your money you need to be
getting what that's worth back which is
why some of the bigger youtubers that
are clearly giving a lot of money and
it's not always ten percent which is
what
I've learned got for the record I'm not
with a network I have not been with a
network for a very long time and even
when I was it was relatively complicated
because I'm in the school of thought
that it doesn't need to exist and I'm
having a difficult time understanding
what network brings to the table for
someone like me that for the majority of
the time is in my house doing my own
thing we just got a green screen yeah
and I don't you know we put we put
sponsorships on the podcast but you
don't turn on my jennamarbles channel
and watch an ad so if I'm not there but
- you know you're going to bring me
brand deals and things like that what
exactly are you offering me in return
for the sum of money every month which
is why it's different for every youtuber
exactly but I think the scope of the
whole situation is changing a lot right
now because of things like social a
little bit because people are starting
to realize well hey this site that's
getting a lot of attention it's backed
by people like shaycarl
it's basically giving you as a Korea as
a channel the power and the tool the
tool is like the information to find out
your Worth and to find out how to
navigate the waters in a system where
somehow networks have become the status
quo exactly so that if you are in the
middle of a country that is not the
United States or Canada or somewhere
where you know some of these youtubers
are hubbed at how you live in the middle
of Sweden and you just [ __ ] confuse
you've no and you can't go knock on
PewDiePie's door and just pick his brain
all you have is YouTube and no one's
giving you a straight up answer you
could go to a thing like this and I
think it's in beta still is it I'm not
little about social Bluebook it might be
it might be in beta but it's it's
getting there like it's got tons of
people signed up but eventually you
could go to something or says it's it's
black and white it's it's math it says
if you have this many eyeballs on your
content or you know you can guarantee
this many views per video or you have
this amount of subscribers or whatever
will pay you this but it's data that
it's
exactly but it's like it's like a you
know it's like a periodic table of
elements that you never learned it's
like this equation that you didn't know
but that's why it's important to keep
your eyes out for information like that
so you can now have those tools that you
can make those decisions you know
honestly you know looking for other
people because that is where the problem
starts like you're you you were looking
for information so people claim to have
it and then they take advantage yeah and
it's also like somewhat secret
information right like people think that
youtubers make this outrageous sum of
money for doing absolutely nothing
because they can tell you you know you
can't make this or whatever these
inflated giant numbers if you were doing
a lot of things I don't nobody is making
you know millions and millions and
millions of dollars a year on Google
Adsense and even if you were you still
need to pay taxes and most people have
corporations and then pay themselves
opinion if you're a channel making that
much money you have 50 employees putting
time into that channel a hundred two
hundred employees it's not like someone
sitting in their rooms making that money
off that sense even PewDiePie where it's
like a PewDiePie makes 50 million yo
dresses he made a you saw the video
right and and even if he did good for
[ __ ] him but you also have to
remember that this is how the internet
culture is they want that those people
that wrote that article did a
mathematical equation where they figured
out the maximum possible income that
someone could make from doing this let's
write that is the title and let's get
everybody to [ __ ] click on it whether
it makes them happy sad hopeful inspired
furious that its clickbait you know what
I mean and for most of us that and Phil
DeFranco has talked about it a lot you
start a corporation and then you pay
yourself a paycheck like anybody else
any of these kids running around with
giant fancy [ __ ] cars and doing crazy
[ __ ] with their money
it's your life it's your money do what
you want but the people that are in it
to make a career that are you know doing
their own [ __ ] thing they are the
ones that aren't over here being like
guys look how much [ __ ] money I have
that's not what it's about it's about
being smart with your money
the corporation which is why it's very
difficult for someone in that mindset to
be like this makes sense for me to give
away 10% of my income when you can
create it for yourself yeah
which is why we have Rome yes Rome is
essentially my Network yes she does
everything from A to B and we pay her
what makes sense and the rest goes into
the company and it's not my money it's
not your money it's the company's money
just like if we are on Twitch and we're
doing stuff it goes back into the
business we got some green-screen [ __ ]
yeah it's not so that you can go be a
piece of [ __ ] yeah I mean it's just
important to keep in mind that you you
like it's you know it's nice to
anticipate and expect the good in people
and things like that but some of these
networks will have no problem [ __ ]
you over and then sleeping at night and
it's just sleeping and I probably not
getting a great night's sleep because
they're probably not on bolin branch
sheets but yeah you could be on bolin
brown sheets if you go to bolin branch
calm right now and check out their
selection they have amazing amazing
super comfortable high quality bedding
it's a husband-wife run company on a
great mission they do great work they
donate a lot of their profit to charity
they're not some sort of big box
retailer and they deliver it right to
your door which is just really really
great Boland branch they just recently
delivered us scarves Wiseau and it
couldn't have been more properly time
because we went and we went to Edmonton
and I had a scarf and it was so nice to
have because uh it was [ __ ] cold but
literally everything that they make the
thread that they produce is just another
level and it feels really expensive but
it's not for betting and for things like
that you know it's affordable which is
great go to Bowman branch calm right now
to check out their selection of awesome
bedding and things like scarves and
everything comfortable and you can enter
Jenna Julianne at checkout for fifty
bucks off your first order and then you
know when you get home and right before
you ready for bed you want to cook a
nice meal but you don't go out shopping
go to blue apron comm and check out
their service it's really great guys you
can select your preferences of what you
like to eat what you can eat your
dietary needs things like
and then you get shipped a beautiful
package right to your front door with
cold packs in it so it stays fresh of
properly prepared and measured out
ingredients for you to literally just
follow the recipe and cook the meal for
yourself we can attest they're
absolutely delicious
and you're kind of like one of the whole
time again how did this arrive in the
mail and still tastes so fresh a
blueprint does great work and they take
out all the the kind of the annoying
part of cooking for yourself they give
you the exact amount like already
measured up you don't even need your
measuring cups anything like that you
just open the box and you tornado all
over the kitchen until you have a
beautiful delicious meal yeah so go to
blue apron calm right now
blue apron calm slash Jenna Julian and
you get your first two meals on us we
will pay for your first two meals trance
about so do you think thanks to our
sponsor to our sponsors um but sorry
sorry for going on my a no no no that's
I feel like that's kind of why we needed
to talk right I know because it's just
it it's a it's a topic that makes me
angry because I understand it boils a
lot down to just what you what you want
what you want for your life what you
want for you know your business or your
career whatever you want to see it as
just what you want because there are
many upsides to signing with a network
this is something you no longer have to
worry about these people can sign a
contract with a network that deal with
everything coming in they deal with
their their bookings of things or their
money their numbers like you don't worry
about stuff but um you could also go
another way which I have chosen to go
where you create your own business and
you know you you do things your way
which it's important to know for smaller
creators out there if you're if any of
you are youtubers with channels that
you're building and you're watching this
it's important to understand that Wow
networks can be bad but they can also be
good if they are not the only option if
you need help right so if you if you
don't feel like taking everything on
your own it's not either networks or
[ __ ] you know it's like there are other
options like Jenna said you know Rome
you can find people who are educated on
the space of the internet who know at
least a little bit who aren't just like
your Hollywood actor agents like people
who kind of get
the Internet and you can work with them
you know I know a lot of youtubers who
have that relationship which is
amazingly beneficial because what you're
doing is you know if you like brand
deals you give them a cut of each brand
deal you know and that's how you guys
have a relationship they want to get you
good deals so they can make a cut it's
not like oh you're signed to the network
we're getting our paycheck every month
no matter what now
you know we'll wait for you to ask for
us for help but it's important to
believe that you can create
relationships that help you that aren't
just kind of cookie cutter Network
things and I'm a big believer because I
feel like within the internet space
there are a lot of people that are
getting ripped off and it's not all
about money but you don't want to be put
in a position where people are taking
advantage of you and this is also why I
went off on a [ __ ] tangent about
[ __ ] money you know people doing bad
things with it or just [ __ ] with it
it's not being smart like it's not that
it's bad whatever what am I trying to
stow so you're talking there's there's
just a lot of people in the world that
are out to rip you off and it's not fair
because you're being held to a and 'red
that does not belong in this space for
example I've heard that networks can
take anywhere up to 30 to 40% of your
channels income and that they can lock
you into two and three year contracts
which should never be the case and even
10% I have a hard time justifying
because if you want my honest opinion my
honest advice is that there's not a
single person unless they are with you
you know working with you unless if
you're like Smosh or we're Jenna
Julianne podcasts there's not someone
that should be taking a percentage of
anything unless it's something that they
are bringing to you so for example I
work with CIA CIA gets paid when they
bring me something yep they get a cut of
that which more than fair this is an
opportunity that wouldn't have existed
can you give an example just for their
sake of what nature of something means
that they bring to you you don't have to
give any like specific names but like
what what is something that CIA
to bring to you like just like a cookie
cutter response like what type of thing
is it's just like an opportunity is it's
like anything right like anything that's
not YouTube video that you're making
yeah like literally from start to finish
no one has anything to do with my
YouTube channel except for yeah yeah
yeah um it would be anything outside
just anything outside of you okay just
so you will know what that means when
she says bring something to me right ah
I don't do any negotiations for anything
on my youtube channel because nothing
was on my youtube channel except for
dumb videos yes and then the rest of my
life you know
is an open book in terms of what I'm
open to anything I'll do whatever but um
what was I going to say
no no there's there's people that want
to rip you off they like they first of
all they take too much they're taking a
percentage of things that they are not
contributing to so we talk about I have
Rome who does everything there's no
reason why if you were out in the world
looking for a year Rome looking for your
manager you should not be then paying
that person a percentage of your Adsense
earning they should be getting you know
maybe a flat salary and then maybe also
a commission based percentage off of
things that they are bringing to you
because I do know people in the YouTube
space that decide that they don't want
to be with the network all right I'm
going to go find a manager and then
they're being held to an old-hollywood
standard like a network standard where
it's like alright we get 10% of every
penny that you make but that that's you
understand why that's wrong like there
there's no reason why network should be
getting you small youtuber 10% of every
penny that you make in your Adsense
because you can make that money without
them there's no need for that you
understand yeah and absolutely and I
think the reason that now some networks
can thrive on that dishonesty is that
nobody's held accountable right like
nobody's going it networks and saying
hey what are you doing like give me a
reason why we're paying you no one's
doing that everyone's like oh I need to
be with the network alright I'm with
Network all right it's okay that I'm
losing this money because I'm with the
network like no one's no one's exposing
no one's paying any attention to or to
holding anyone responsive bill at these
networks for not doing anything and then
taking money from people who aren't even
really getting it right and in my
opinion no one should be having you sign
a contract to work with them for more
than a year ever that I mean I'm sure
there's some wiggle room depending on
your situation but if you're a youtuber
looking to sign with a network that
needs to first of all make sure that you
have a lawyer I can't stress that enough
a lawyer needs to look over things for
you period
just don't sign things just because
someone told you to that's a nightmare a
lawyer needs to look over especially a
network contract because a lot of them
are signing kids fifteen-year-olds their
parents are signing them into three-year
contracts which is an absolute eternity
on the internet so what does that mean
for they're not going to get like if
you're a 15 year old creator you may
involve video now you're popular and
buying YouTube whatever and you sign it
through your concert without owning up
what does that mean that essentially
means that your deal with them is
effective for the next three years and
good luck god help you if you ever want
to get out of it so what's required of
them they have to create things for
three years you'd have to read your
specific contract but it basically says
that you know no matter what you do no
matter what happens probably even if you
die you owe X Network X amount of your
earnings period and I just don't think
that people are really thinking about
that or understanding that they just see
it as like all right I need support okay
this means that now I'm more legitimate
because I've signed with the network and
you do have another option which is go
out find somebody to work with you and
do it by yourself because the harder
road obviously is figuring out how to do
things yourself people don't want to
[ __ ] do that but I do understand
signing with the network just make sure
that you're smart about it and that
you're protecting yourself because there
are people that are designed to [ __ ] you
over like the email please don't ever
sign up with a network through email
Yeah right that shimmy because it's like
and if you if you ever decide to work
with somebody outside of YouTube that's
not a network please don't ever give
someone a percentage of your earnings
take that money and invest it back into
your business and your company and in
whatever you're doing
I just infuriates me when I talk to
these people
I've been propositioned by a lawyer to
give him a percentage of my income a
business manager like there's been so
many people that emerge companies want a
percentage of your income you know
regardless of what you're doing there's
just so many people that will come to
you and be like no this this is this is
how it is because they assume that
you're young and you're stupid and you
don't know any better and that you
should just sign this contract that says
that you're giving them X amount of
money or X percentage of your money
which is insane and there is a lot of
money to be made on the Internet and
they know that that's that's all I gotta
say
there's just no reason why someone
should be making a percentage of money
nobody [ __ ] says that for some reason
is just a status quo to give people
[ __ ] percentages that's an old
Hollywood standard that is not how new
media should work I think you're
absolutely right I'm [ __ ] pissed off
but it mean here's the thing like I I
know little to nothing about having you
know experiences with this stuff I'm
looking at it from the outside but I
feel like I have grasped a fair amount
of the dynamic that exists and I guess
like the only thing that I can stress
because I have nowhere near the
experience or knowledge that you have
but the only thing that I can express is
that a lot of times especially when
you're younger and you and you have
power whether it's with the content you
create or the audience that you carry
people will throw big words around and
it's just so important to speak English
because you know a lot of times you're
intimidated to just kind of ask a
straight-up question like okay so all
this call what you just said what does
this mean every single month what am I
giving you what are you giving like
sometimes it really just says it's so
simplifying exactly as always this plan
because you don't know any better when
you're a young person just charting out
you just need some help yeah so I mean
it's flawed and it's scary that network
and prey on people who are kind of
ill-equipped to deal with that but you
know the that's what I'm saying is like
sometimes as much as it feels like
you're it's impossible to do just just
dumb everything down to make them give
you the straight-up facts and have it in
writing though have a lawyer or sober
worse yeah you got a carpentry a network
contract or even if you're working with
friends family someone independently
have a contract drafted up sign it have
a lawyer look it over just make sure
that you're protected regardless of
anything that can happen in the future
just make sure that you know everything
stays intact for you because it's just
it can it can get really messy yeah and
unfortunately I started with the best of
intentions I think anybody starts with
the best of intentions you don't
necessarily set out to do anything but
just have fun and laugh yeah and and
that was the case for me and I went into
everything with really great
rose-colored glasses on and you just
sort of figure out that not everyone
thinks that way but there are a lot of
people out there that just want to take
your money and like [ __ ] you over which
is disheartening and you don't even if
you've had a bad experience you you can
do plenty of other things to make sure
that you have a happy you know career
the best that you can after that
experience you don't have to be jaded by
anything just from that so to anyone in
the YouTube community that you know
maybe you're having a difficult time
it's very difficult for me to remember a
time when I've talked to someone and
they'll be like hey are you with the
network and I'm like no are you with the
network and they'll go yeah with blah
blah blah [ __ ] sucks I'm in this
contract for like three years they're
taking X percent like it's very I'm
hard-pressed to remember a time having a
conversation with someone when they were
just like totally in love with being
with the network it's funny to think
about because it's so ridiculous yeah I
never ever happened I mean I can't I
think it's possible
maybe they maybe they don't bring it up
in conversation because they're so
over-the-moon happy maybe they only
bring it up in conversation because
they're going through a bumpy time and
they want some
yeah but I just know that you have
options and just know if you're in a
contract make sure you read the [ __ ] out
of that contract because a lot of them
have the you need to give 30 to 60 days
legal written notice in order to be
released from that crash or else it
automatically renews sometimes for
double the amount of time um just really
sketchy stuff so I hate to burst the
bubble for people that watch this
podcast that just you know don't want to
[ __ ] listen to anyway I'm sorry if we
bored you if you're not involved
directly I just feel like this is what I
hold it you know yeah I hope it really
does help somebody out there and feel
like they might be a little more well
equipped to deal with the very
frustrating scary waters of navigating
your own career or life and it is scary
yeah it's scary you know it's it's a big
deal so don't ever feel like like you're
wrong for feeling nervous about things
or feeling weird about even if even if
you're like you like everyone else or
with the network it's okay to be like
wait a minute I'm going to question this
right now because it doesn't in my oh my
guts disagreeing with it a lot of the
times that's the hardest part it's
convincing yourself to just like believe
your own gut when everything else is
telling you the other the other you know
the other way so well the people that
watch YouTube videos are smart though
too like they they know for a fact when
things are sketchy when they're being
like spoon-fed some [ __ ] that they
don't need to see like I know that some
networks have clauses in them that are
like you need to collaborate with other
members of our network in order to
cross-promote them you need to do all
this is don't take this as like these
are just like horror stories done things
yes yeah but it does definitely exist
where they can write anything that they
want into that contract I'm trying to
you know go through my brain thinking of
people will be like well why is it a big
deal to sign this contract if you're
with somebody is just about the 10% it's
not about the money it's about them
being able to control you in ways that
you then can't work with
they're people not like other youtubers
you you literally cannot go just like
create something that you wanted to you
it's not like you go then release an
album or you know it's all contingent on
your particular contract with a network
but they're very complicated in that a
lot of it is exclusive so you can't just
go do a project that you wanted on the
side or do anything other than your
YouTube channel if you wrote a book or
you wrote a pilot TV show you cannot you
can't just go pitch it to somebody
without your network so the implications
of signing is not just about handing
someone 10% of your income it's about
really handing over your entire life and
livelihood to a company to a corporation
of freedom that yes that might not have
your best interests at heart and this
although it's not harder percent related
but you know Twitter was freaking out
today in particular about Kesha being
with dr. Luke in within Sony and she had
her court hearing today which got denied
for her to be free from Sony's contract
even though dr. Luke sexually assaulted
her so she claims but that that's the
type of agreement that you sign when you
sign with the network but any last three
[ __ ] like that yes even if you say well
this person [ __ ] raped me yeah you
can't legally get out of this contract
so that's like what I'm saying is not
you know it's about your 10% or it's
about your 20% or your whatever it's
literally your freedom as a human being
is being compromised and if you do sign
with a network take it more seriously
take it as like a marriage or a
relationship you are being legally bound
as one entity with another person or
company or thing for X amount of time
for a lot of people it's a huge chunk of
time and in my opinion to sign something
longer than a year is an eternity on
even one year is an eternity on the
internet for these people to be signing
two three five-year contracts there's
just
no way of knowing where the internet is
going to be out in five years we've
talked about that on here before how
matter networks in time so or where you
personally are going to be out in five
years no and I think that it's become
such a status thing within YouTube to
say I'm with this network so you know
[ __ ] with me it's a big part of it but
if you are a smaller youtuber and you're
being approached by a network a
legitimate network that you know is not
just you know [ __ ] you have needs to
be fulfilled and professional and you
have talked to somebody and you think
like it's a good fit for you make sure
you negotiate with them you know don't
let them take money from you that you
don't think is fair ah
make sure it's a smart amount of time
and if they tell you well this is what
we have everybody sign you know that
you're just another person like sign
this that's not the network for you yeah
they need to be doing what's fair and
what's right and if they're not willing
to do that then keep going on your own
because I promise you you'll be getting
farther by yourself unless you want to
[ __ ] on a brand deals in which case wait
for one of these applications like a
blue book social Bluebook or a niche to
become available to you to use and you
know do the best that you can to field
inquiries as they're sent to you
independently because you'll be better
off and you'll be happier and you don't
owe anybody your soul and you don't have
to you know go and try and get out of a
contract that you can't legally get out
of yep I mean hopefully there are a few
of you that this this helped her you
know he benefited it all from hearing
this don't ever underestimate you know
Jenna's word and when it comes to stuff
like this because she's been through a
lot of different times of the internet
and she's seen a lot of different
changes and changing at the garden just
the way it works and it's just it's
important to value all the information
given out it's just one of those just
one of those things you know you really
have to watch your own back in a world
where people won't watch it for you if
you don't watch it for yourself but I
mean if there was something that you
were unclear about you know leave it in
the comments we'll do our best to
to say and it will just my last closing
thought is that the the people that you
like on the internet or that you wish
you could ask for advice like I have the
freedom to tell you what I think about
networks just as a whole and anybody has
that but many people that if you ask
them about their specific experience
with X network you sign a nondisclosure
agreement so if you're sort of like well
why isn't anyone telling me actually
legally can which networks suck which
which networks are good which one should
I sign with a lot of people legally
cannot speak poorly report against
certain networks so just know that I I
would like to say you know probably 70
million other things as would anybody
would love to scream at the top of their
lungs you know maybe some of the wrong
things that networks have done to them
in the past but they're not legally
allowed to and it's not out of lack of
caring for other people are looking out
for other people it's just because they
can't yeah and I I don't even know if I
was supposed to say that or [ __ ] at all
you can't allowed to say that I mean
people need to know that that kind of
thing is a thing but yeah it's you know
it's the this is an easy but it's a very
difficult podcast to do because we want
to say all this stuff but we don't
really want to say all this stuff you
know boy I will say for for my current
time like where I am at personally I
don't really know all this stuff that's
going on with networks right now because
I'm removed from it all I know is that
if a company collective fullscreen
anybody that comes to me with specific
things more than happy to work with any
of them I just don't want to necessarily
some representative I yeah I think that
that's always a possibility and you know
you don't need to burn any bridges or be
angry at anybody or you know anything
like that you just keep your keep as
many options for yourself open as you
can um and to each is own and there's
still all very nice people a lot of time
yes very nice they're just you know
doing business how they have to do
business in order to make money which
oftentimes is off of the backs of young
kids that sadness hurt anyway thank you
guys for hanging out with us for this
podcast sorry if it wasn't something
that applied to you but hopefully for
those that it did apply to you got
something out of it and there's
information here that you can use like I
said leave comments have a discussion
we'll try to get through the comments
and and respond to you guys but yeah I
mean thanks for bearing with us in a
podcast that's yeah and less than happy
and hilarious it's more of just like no
we're gonna talk about some [ __ ] right
now if I said anything that you were
confused about um or out of just like
pure scatterbrained because I have so
many thoughts I'm very passionate about
this um I will try my best if you have
questions in the comments of this
YouTube video to try and clear them up
for you know um the best that I can
yeah for sure yes we don't want you guys
I just black out because I'm Sophia and
yeah we're not trying to compete you
guys though um but uh thank you for
hanging out thanks to our sponsors go
check out a blue apron calm right now
slash Jenna Julianne that's blue apron
calm / - Angelina your first two meals
for free on us might deliver to your
door and you will you if you try that
you will get the taste of the
ingredients and the quality of their
stuff it's hard to not to not go back
because it's really convenient and it's
wonderful so thank you blue apron and
Bowlin branch go to Bowlin branch comm
enter product code Jenna Julian and you
get 50 bucks off your first order of
bedding scarves whatever it is that you
need comfort in they have you covered
luxury luxury stuff for affordable
prices and you get $50 off so thanks to
her sponsors
and thanks for hanging another week on
the Jenna Jillian podcast hopefully I
being sick enjoyed it Jenna
unfortunately wasn't a hundred percent
but she came out again oh my god that's
your favorite when I cough and it turns
it to his knees did you do that yeah
yeah sure like cough cough cough and
then sneeze it's like really cute
but yeah you were ng coming out with a
cold and dominating the [ __ ] podcast
so I appreciate you coming out and
braving your unfortunate condition you
made that sound like way more important
than what I just did
do you know I'm talking about when MJ
was sick and he had the [ __ ] game of
his life that's what you didn't run out
you just laid down some knowledge no
knowledge girl mm-hmm knowledge watch
somebody [ __ ] sue me in this video
get ripped down and then I also just
disappear all right that is enough of
those bad thoughts that is not for
heaven all right thanks for watching
guys